KELSEY KRIPPAEHNE: Hey.
Welcome.
In this session,
we're going to be
talking about applying
Kubernetes app
development and best practices.
We're going to talk about
what are the best practices,
and then we're going to give a
demo on how we use Google Cloud
DevTools to implement them.
First, we'd like to
introduce ourselves.
I'm Kelsey Krippaehne.
I'm a developer relations
engineer at Google.
ABBY CAREY: And I'm Abby Carey,
developer advocate for Google
Cloud's developer experiences.
KELSEY KRIPPAEHNE: So as
with any type of development,
following best practices
when working with Kubernetes
can save you time and
unnecessary frustration.
You may have to write lots
of YAML configuration files.
So unless you're a
YAML expert, you'll
want to have authoring
support so that you don't
have to constantly look up
what property takes what fields
or memorize the basic
components of a service.
For local Kubernetes
development,
you don't need to replicate
your production cluster.
But it's important to have
a cluster for local dev
that's configured in
a way that ensures
that what you're
building will be
compatible with the
production cluster.
Using commands like
kubectl logs to inspect
pods and services works
OK, but trying to parse
logs this way can be a pain,
especially for beginners.
A tailored logging interface
is a more efficient way
to get the info
you're looking for.
Debugging Kubernetes with
CLI commands is cumbersome.
Once again, using a
tool that's tailored
for Kubernetes
debugging can save you
from a lot of frustration.
Excessive time to
build and deploy--
it's always a best practice to
improve development velocity
and not get stuck in
a lengthy build cycle
on every change
to the code base.
And finally, it's
a best practice
to share best practices.
If your team has specific
policies for developing
Kubernetes apps,
those patterns should
be accessible as
project templates
that your team can reuse
to ensure conformity
and to make it easy for
new devs to onboard.
So we're going to start
implementing these best
practices with
Google's Cloud Code.
Cloud Code is an IDE plugin
that automates dev workflows
for cloud-native applications.
You can see Cloud Code
as sort of a bridge
between you developing in
your IDE and Google Cloud.
It's bringing the cloud to you.
Cloud Code is
particularly helpful
when developing with
Kubernetes because it
comes pre-installed with
tools like Skaffold, minikube,
and the Cloud SDK.
Skaffold is a command
line tool that
handles the workflow
for building, pushing,
and deploying your application.
Cloud Code uses Skaffold
behind the scenes,
so it acts as sort of a user
interface for the Skaffold CLI.
minikube sets up a local
Kubernetes cluster.
It's small but powerful and
extremely beginner-friendly.
Cloud Code is available for
VS Code and JetBrains IDEs,
like IntelliJ.
You can also try out Cloud
Code on Google's web-based IDE,
the Cloud Shell Editor.
All of these tools--
Cloud Code, Cloud Shell,
Skaffold, and minikube--
are 100% free to use.
And we encourage you, if you
want to try it out right now,
go ahead and install
Cloud Code on your IDE
or try it out in
your web browser
with this link to an
interactive tutorial.
So we've talked
about best practices
and how it can be difficult
to implement them.
The question now is, how do
these Google Cloud DevTools
make it easy to incorporate best
practices into your Kubernetes
development workflow?
First, you don't need to
be a YAML expert in order
to write functional
Kubernetes resource manifests.
Tools like Cloud Code
that provide YAML snippets
and autocompletes make
it so that you can author
entire Kubernetes
manifests without looking
at YAML documentation.
You should be developing
on a cluster that
replicates your production
cluster as much as
possible to avoid issues
when pushing to production.
You can configure
a minikube cluster
to quickly develop and test
locally with no added cost.
You can also use Skaffold
to create distinct profiles
for dev versus prod
and incorporate
customized [INAUDIBLE] for
even more powerful deployment
workflows.
As mentioned before,
it's a good idea
to use a dedicated logging
tool that makes Kubernetes
logs more accessible.
With Cloud Code's
new logging support,
you can drill down into your
containers and container builds
and your deployment logs.
And you'll see that in
a minute in the demo.
For debugging, sometimes
prints and log statements
just aren't enough.
It's useful to be able
to step through the code.
Cloud Code brings Kubernetes
debugging into your IDE.
It lets you do
step-by-step debugging live
in your Kubernetes cluster,
locally and remotely,
using the IDE's debugging
interface that you're already
familiar with.
Having an automated
local dev loop
is a general best
practice, and you
can setup Kubernetes iterative
development using Skaffold.
Skaffold has a file
sync functionality
that prevents you from needing
to rebuild and redeploy
your containers on
every little change.
And finally, you can use a
tool like Cloud Code's custom
samples to create
project templates
or samples to easily distribute
your team's best practices.
With custom samples, you can
have a reusable Kubernetes
configured app that your
team can access right
from their IDE.
And now I'll hand things
over to Abby for a demo.
ABBY CAREY: Thanks, Kelsey.
Let's get into IntelliJ
and see some of these best
practices in action.
To kick off this
demo, I'll show how
you can Kubernetify
a non Kubernetes
application with Skaffold.
I already have Cloud Code
installed from the JetBrains
marketplace, which
means Skaffold
has been installed, too, since
it's a managed dependency.
I'll use Skaffold's init
--generate-manifests command
to get this app working
with Kubernetes in seconds.
And I want to mention that
this functionality will soon
be added to Cloud Code's UI.
You can view Cloud
Code as a frontend
for Skaffold, which is
a command-line tool.
And now Skaffold's going to
prompt me to pick my builder.
And for my frontend, I will
be building with Buildpacks.
And for my backend, I'll use
the existing Dockerfile here.
Skaffold looks at my
application and determines
what the Kubernetes
resources are,
and then it creates a
deployment.yaml file
for each one.
And now that that's
finished, I have
manifests generated
for my application,
and a skaffold.yaml
file that specifies
it's a build-and-deployment
pipeline.
We'll take a closer look
at skaffold.yaml later.
This application is
ready for Kubernetes,
but these manifests that were
generated are starting points.
You will likely want
to customize them.
Your organization may have
certain naming patterns
or file system layouts.
In this case, this
application needs
some environment
variables and labels
for the frontend and
backend containers,
and an additional
Kubernetes resource
to deploy a MongoDB
service for our database.
I've added a version
of this application
with these changes made to a
Custom Samples Git repository.
Cloud Code's Custom
Samples feature
allows your organization
to easily distribute
best practices by letting
developers connect
their IDEs to custom sample
repos, which I've already
done here.
A team best practice is to
have starter projects that
are setup to fit your team's
preferred configurations.
When talking in the
context of K8s development,
this would include
run configurations
and certain YAML files.
And my new ready-to-go
sample is called Nextbook,
so I'll create it.
The Nextbook application
is a basic Kubernetes app
with a frontend and
backend service.
We've kept this demo app
simple to better demonstrate
complex Kubernetes dev flows.
It includes logic to read
from and write to a database,
and displays the most
recently added database entry.
Let's take a look at the
contents of this project.
This project is
configured to use
Skaffold for both development
and production workflows.
That's all setup with
this skaffold.yaml file.
I've also set up
runConfigurations in my .idea
folder.
By committing these files
to your project's repo,
this enables any developer
to run and develop
your application the same way.
This helps with onboarding
in a team environment.
skaffold.yaml ties
the container images
we're going to build
to the K8s resources
we're going to deploy.
Skaffold supports a number
of container image builders,
like Docker, Jib, Ko, and more.
I've already setup
my Skaffold file
to build my backend with a
Dockerfile and my frontend
image with buildpacks.
Buildpacks are a set of
opinionated image builders
that encode language-specific
best practices
for containerizing applications.
They save you from having
to write custom Dockerfiles.
Skaffold profiles are very
powerful for separating
configurations for different
uses or environments,
including build, test, and
deployment configurations.
I have two already set for
development and production,
which is a best practice.
My dev profile applies
development settings,
which shouldn't be
enabled in production.
One of our new products,
Google Cloud Deploy,
leverages Skaffold profiles to
gather configuration details
for each target environment.
I'll dig deeper into
the Skaffold file
as I go through this demo.
Cloud Code automatically
installs necessary tools,
like Skaffold, so
we're ready to start
working on this application.
Cloud Code comes with
a Kubernetes Explorer.
This gives you a view of all
your deployed K8s resources
and is an excellent
tool for operators.
Looking closer at one
of my existing clusters
I've deployed to, I can
explore my deployed resources,
and even shell into a running
pod to run some commands.
Cloud Code supports any
conformant Kubernetes cluster,
whether that's a local
cluster, like minikube or k3d,
or hosted by a cloud provider.
Today, I'll be deploying
this application
to my GKE dev cluster.
For this sample app,
my run configurations
are already defined
so that any developer
can run this application on
IntelliJ the same way I would.
I have two configurations--
development and production.
It's a best practice
to tailor workflows
for different contexts.
Let's take a look at my
development configuration.
This is a Cloud Code
Kubernetes configuration
that I've built on.
My container register
URL is already set,
and this is needed because my
skaffold.yaml doesn't specify
an image repository, allowing
developers to easily deploy
to multiple locations.
An example of this is if you
have a personal dev repository
and a production repository.
My Run configuration is set
to run on my GKE dev cluster.
The option to automatically
rebuild and rerun
turns on Skaffold's watch mode
for iterative development.
In the Build-Deploy
section, we already
have a Skaffold file, so
nothing needs to be done here.
As a side note, though, if you
don't have a Skaffold file,
this is the spot where you'd
be prompted to initialize one
with just a couple clicks.
One last thing I want to
touch on before running
is that I have a Deployment
profile set named dev.
dev is one of my
Skaffold profiles
that I already defined
in skaffold.yaml.
Looking at my
skaffold.yaml file again,
my dev profile specifies
a Dockerfile target, dev,
for my backend Dockerfile.
Now taking a look at
my backend Dockerfile,
you'll see that
it's multi-staged.
With my dev target set,
running my configuration
will build the base image,
along with the dev portion here,
turning on my Flask
backend's debug mode.
And if the target
were set to prod,
which is for my production
run configuration,
my Flask debugger would be
turned off in production mode.
Now I'll focus on my dev cluster
in the Kubernetes Explorer
and run this with my
development configuration.
Right now, Cloud Code
is building and pushing
my container images
to my cluster.
Now that that's done,
Cloud Code port forwards
my cluster's services
to my local machine,
so all I have to do is click
the link for my frontend.
You can also explicitly
set up port forwarding
for other resources, like
deployments or stateful sets
in skaffold.yaml.
Now let's take a look
at this application.
And this is my
application running
remotely on my GKE cluster.
Everything is
looking as expected,
so I'll enter a new
entry to the database.
And yep, my output box is
displaying the latest entry.
Deploying an app to a cluster
generates a ton of logs.
Loading container images,
deployments, spinning up pods,
and the logs streaming from your
containers all generate logs.
Figuring out the best way
to view all these logs
can require running
multiple kubectl commands.
Cloud Code splits the logs
up into easily selectable
sections.
This makes finding where errors
occurred in your deployment
process easy.
Logs are also streamed
for each container,
letting you focus on different
components of your application.
So right now we're still
running our application,
and Skaffold's watch mode is
waiting for us to make changes.
Now let's look at the YAML
of our deployed application
and see if we can
make it better follow
Kubernetes best practices.
We don't have a readiness
probe, and you should always
have one so that Kubernetes
knows when your app is
ready to serve traffic.
This gets us a
step closer towards
zero-downtime deployments
and higher availability.
We're going to use Cloud
Code's YAML authoring
support to create
this probe real quick.
I'll go down to my container
and press Control-Space.
And there's the option
for a readinessProbe.
Now to add some parameters.
I'll press Control-Space
again and pick tcpSocket.
My port is 8080.
What other parameters
do I need, though?
Hovering over readinessProbe
shows me documentation,
and I see that I have
a couple more options.
Now I'll add
initialDelaySeconds, set to 5,
and periodSeconds, set to 5.
That's looking good.
Now I'll save this file.
Skaffold's watch
mode just kicked off
and we're redeploying.
And now it's done.
Our readiness probe is ready.
This whole rebuilding
and redeploying process
is pretty fast, but
we can make it faster,
and that is with file sync.
By setting up Skaffold's
file sync feature,
you can copy over a local
file that you've just
edited with one in your
deployed container in seconds.
This avoids the need to
rebuild, redeploy, and restart
your corresponding
pod on a file change,
saving you local
development time.
To get file sync working
with my backend's Dockerfile,
a little extra
configuration is needed.
But to save a little time,
I've already done that.
I'm using inferred syncing when
using my dev Skaffold profile.
This means that Skaffold
will look at my Dockerfile
to determine the location of
where my edited files should
be synced to.
All you need to do is tell
Skaffold what files to watch.
I've added *.py so that any
Python file in my backend that
I edit will trigger a sync.
My frontend automatically
has file sync
turned on, because it's
being built with buildpacks.
This autosync feature is
specific to buildpacks.
There are file type limitations
when using buildpacks,
but JavaScript is supported,
so my frontend syncing
is good to go.
File sync may require
configuring your web framework
to detect and respond
to file changes.
I'm using Flask's development
mode to restart the app
on a .py change.
For compiled languages
or frameworks
that don't provide
this support, you'll
need to use an
external file watcher,
like Nodemon or Watchexec.
If you're building
with buildpacks,
Watchexec is
automatically configured.
Now let's see if we can
sync a backend Python file.
To visually test this,
I'll hard code a new entry
into the output text box
that says, This is syncing.
Now I'll open my Run
window back up and save it.
My logs are showing
that a sync just
finished, so let's check out my
Kubernetes app now and give it
a refresh.
And there is that data
I just set in there.
With Skaffold's file
syncing, locally iterating
on a deployed Kubernetes
application is super fast.
Now let's talk about debugging.
There are a ton of ways to
debug a Kubernetes application.
But what if debugging it
was as simple as debugging
any application in your IDE?
You should run and
debug your applications
in environments that
closely mimic production,
so why not remotely
on a GKE cluster?
I could also switch to
using a local minikube
cluster to cut down on latency.
But since we're already
talking about GKE clusters,
I'll stick with that.
So now I'm going
to try and debug
my frontend's app.js file.
And all I should need to
do is place a breakpoint.
I'll set it to trigger
after I post a message.
And now I'll kick off debugging
with Cloud Code's debug mode.
And once I've set my paths
for my frontend and backend
containers, I can now
open up my application
and post a message to see if
we can trigger this breakpoint.
And there we go.
I'm now remotely debugging my
application on my GKE cluster
right from my IDE.
I'll just step through
the code a couple times
and then finish running it.
Super simple.
It's a good practice to add
tests for your container image,
and Skaffold supports
running tests.
For the last part
of this demo, I'm
going to run container
structure tests with Skaffold.
Container structure tests
validate the structure
of your container image,
can check command outputs,
and verify file
content and metadata.
Here we have test files for
the backend and frontend
containers.
These files are written in
YAML, but you can also use JSON.
In the backend, I'm checking
that Python is installed
and that the requirements
file exists in the container.
In the frontend,
I'm testing to make
sure I don't have any
comments that include xxx left
in my code, because I
definitely don't want
to push those into production.
So my tests are written.
Now let's go over
to skaffold.yaml.
In my prod profile,
I've configured Skaffold
to run the container tests.
Now after Skaffold
builds the image,
it'll run the tests before
deploying to the cluster.
I'll switch to my
production run configuration
and see if these tests pass.
Looks like one of my
tests didn't pass.
Let's take a closer look.
So my backend
container test passed,
but it looks like my frontend
container has a comment that's
causing this to fail.
I'll go fix that right now.
I'll delete this comment
here and give it a run
one more time.
And everything passed this time.
This application is now
ready for production,
thanks to Google
Cloud's dev tools,
like Cloud Code and Skaffold.
Thanks for following
along with us today.
And if you want to check
out the demo we used,
you can find it on GitHub.
To try these tools out yourself
and maybe with your team,
install Cloud Code from
your IDE's marketplace.
And finally, we encourage
you to join the conversation
at Cloud Code's Slack channel.
And on behalf of Kelsey
and I, thank you again,
and enjoy the rest of Next.